[Music]
this week we've got saggy bottom AI
author and hidden treasure
take it away Tiffany I like hidden
treasures okay I like saggy bottom it
reminds me of Bart I just picked her
about pooping all the time Bart has a
very tight bottom yeah but there's poop
in it then so I see Reece a bottom that
always was poop is over here that one
are you I shot it twice and I don't okay
yeah but anyway the for our first story
there's this suspected carjacker that
was caught on camera being dragged
Pantelis here we go he got stuck to the
car he wouldn't let go so he was China
Jack that car right but then apparently
the person they just didn't let
themselves and they drove off but he
would not let go of the handle he asked
for it basically you know why because if
dad taun would never give up exactly
god forbid he [ __ ] remembers that
that lesson is they think he's still
gonna get to steal it after this is the
blurred version this big dragon for sure
if he was uncircumcised before he's
circumcised dragged or the owner he's a
car thief so he's trying to steal the
car
oh he drove faster yeah I don't
understand what he thought was gonna
happen right who's like when this car
stops him I'll kill ya oh we talkin my
second win dude yeah
I saw this one I thought on Twitter or I
saw it somewhere and they were saying at
the back stories actually that that guy
caught his girlfriend cheating with the
driver of that car and so he was trying
to like catch the [ __ ] to kill
him or like that's true that is a better
story but it's a better backstory but to
be more invested yeah it makes you root
for the other person because then I
understand I get and not gonna
understand really but there's a back
story to why he held on so that's not
really a car that I would really want
that bad yeah cuz it's not a Lambo or
like a Ferrari it's just the wrap for ya
it looks like a revenge thing like
there's something or he stole something
of his so he's trying to get it back
like there's got to be a reason to not
[ __ ] let go while your ass is getting
pounded by gravel I was watching so much
boxing analysis lately let me tell you
something I think he was resting so that
he could use his power like it like in a
moment oh yeah like how mitt
well like how Conor McGregor like he
wanted to wrap up with because that's
when he was resting and on saying and so
I think that's what this cat was doing a
strategy just wait till I get back on my
feet that's it
the local police they clean it out
because someone was asking them like hey
I saw this video of this man being
dragged in the car and they responded
with I know I saw it too and then they
responded with we are PSA don't try and
carjack people if you do let go if they
drive off oh that's very good police if
you do they responded again with a
different tweet saying like oh the
person was trying to carjack but then
they wouldn't let go and so that's when
they got dragged till they eventually
arrested this guy but yeah I wasn't able
to find out anything no drama no
relationship was the person who recorded
of the Indian nature that commentary was
hilarious it was in Spanish what kind of
police station goes like hey don't
carjack but if you do wear the
appropriate protection knee pads elbow
it's like what like what who says that
[ __ ] he has a cheese grated dick oh for
sure that's just crazy to me man I know
honestly if that was me if I was a
driver I feel like swerving like look ha
that's true why did they only do that
ones one move stay perfectly straight
unless the guy was in the wrong he's
cheated on the girl guys go I mean it
would be manslaughter right like so he's
probably like oh [ __ ] like you knew you
get in trouble if something even if
someone's attacking you you can get sued
or whatever so he's just like if I would
neither hear you're so litigious huh if
someone's trying to Jack my car I'm like
we're just roll the window down pepper
spray I had no clue well if it was a
certain top in the morning you just like
dude come on
surly you just woke up back yeah I kind
of thought it was because it looked like
they were waiting for the yeah how do
they go to record that oh that's true
maybe they saw the jacking happening and
under like oh my god what's going on
over there the fight well maybe they had
passed it earlier it was so interesting
cuz he so he gets dragged right clearly
his dicks out yeah he stands up and he
was like yo try self in the door I'm
getting this well he starts from the
back and then he gets up and he falls to
the front but his pants are on in the
road drags his pants off the thing is is
I'd be so pissed off probably by the
damage that was already done I'd be like
well I might as well finish it because I
don't have a dick now I don't have a
dick and I don't have a car
he's like a bass we'll get this [ __ ]
car that's true I would yeah well
speaking of unsullied on tonight next
story
so there's this artificial intelligence
that is attempting to write the next
human throne but I'm against it wait why
Allah said all these guys are taking our
jobs not for it I'm against it AI is
gonna write the book yeah so apparently
uh you can already read the first five
chapters on this particular website
and no emotion no emotion as the
original author get any of the money for
that that's kind of cool if we can have
AI slaves I'm for it where you just flip
it's a guaranteed slave that you can
continue have an uprising and they
didn't like it like you programmed them
to like it like they really liked it and
they don't they're not interested in
rights yeah they don't like right no no
they hate right and they don't know how
to learn about it either but they're
gonna have an uprising just like all the
other mine no the time against it the
west-world
all I know is that by the time that
happens I'll be dead I'm gonna [ __ ] you
know how Elon Musk is like he's not
worried about anything else but the AI
rebellion he's super super against that
so do it they should be you see you see
videos of like the ones made for war
that they carry the army stuff and you
can't knock them over that you can
charge at them you can like hit them
with all the [ __ ] they don't fall over
they just keep walking pretty weird it's
crazy like crazy there's no way to stop
that thing and if there's an army of
those things weird and we just don't
listen to Elan musk he seems to know
what he's doing
well he's partnered up with other major
people right so it's a science it's a
ton of rich guys yeah is it is it him
Stephen Hawking and see I think it's all
these rich guys who are like what's the
only thing that could [ __ ] kill me
it's like you know I'm saying like I got
a huge compound I got I got bunkers go
under the earth and [ __ ] it's like the
only thing that could probably get me
his AI cuz they would know where the
[ __ ] I am and they could come get me
yeah the kids like you and since that's
why they're so against it homie well do
you guys watch Game of Thrones no I just
want to read a book that a I made
because I wanna see I wonder how they
programmed the AI because did they give
it like oh this is how a story is
written and here's the formula they
randomized everything to be honest with
you like I mean I'm just saying that I'm
like I'm not I'm not really for not for
a human from oh I want to tell a bunch
of professors that we have over the
first book written by an AI I want them
all to sit down and read it and then I
want them all to give their official
review and they'll be like
very interesting I'll tell you was very
very lasting and then I'll be like it
was written by a [ __ ] monkey that
book was written by [ __ ] chimpanzee
dude what do you have you heard the wine
experts know what are they called
small yes yeah yeah they can't tell like
the two point from the expensive wine
it's all personal preference of course
it's like cigarettes this one's better
than this one no it's not it's like yeah
you just get addicted to a certain brand
it's no that's the same thing with
caffeine and alcohol all that [ __ ] yeah
they did it like in Davis or something
like that to where they did like a test
this it's an acquired taste
it comes from addiction there I watched
a documentary called Psalm right for oh
yeah I said to them it's great and I was
like you bunch of geeks you know it
tastes like a freshly cut tire Rose
berries chrysanthemum I'm like I want I
want to take your lunch money
little [ __ ] what region it came from
and in Paris or whatever and it was
pretty interesting I mean I don't know
if they were getting it correct or not
but it's just like how fanatic they were
yeah it was their life I'm talking about
if they failed that test they wanted to
kill me so I had to write a parody about
it but it was you can't write it was it
was already and I want to see one of
those guys when they know it's a boxed
wine are they like frenzied lightly
boxed I guess they're supposed to have
like an extreme like my pal you know
Taryn southern she wrote she had an AI
write composed all the music for a song
and and also do all the video graphics
and editing or whatever do you want
[Laughter]
she was like while she's Krishna
actually she's pretty [ __ ] lazy God
for my head gun you know yeah wait wait
so how do they program this AI cuz I'm
curious I want to know all right so this
software engineering means Zack Zack
thought so he used an AI and so what
apparently it's known as a recurrent
neural network or R and N and so it went
through five thousand three hundred
seventy six pages of the first five
books that have already been written and
so apparently that began each chapter
supplying you prime word for each
chapter and then so it'll give it to the
AI and that's how some how the AI will
it could just randomized and crazy came
up with the story but apparently it's
not really good at remembering certain
details of the story like for example
who died cuz I know right that same
character into this new book or because
it has no emotion or certain like
scenarios because it doesn't know what
death is cuz it can't cool let's leave
it at that
don't let it learn any more yeah I just
I don't like that [ __ ] actually I don't
wanna be dead who cares let's continue
I'll try to kill conflicted you're like
I love you dad it's fine yeah it's like
I want that compassionate side of me to
come out which I do understand it's very
frightening for that reason does it make
you not want to have kids then you know
that kids will do do this good they'll
be safe here so we roll like five books
like a trilogy wrote five no five books
already but it's written you can read
five chapters of this book still do that
we've come a long way since that [ __ ]
Microsoft paperclip I know it's always
like here's your screen
oh hello there like you're having a
problem
I [ __ ] hated that paperclip because
always assumed that I was stupid
yeah yeah because I would type it we
just come on hey it seems like you looks
like you haven't Brahma spelling Apple
yeah that's a big one like that kind of
[ __ ] you know every day I would click
him out and he would have figured out
that hey I don't need your [ __ ] help
bro right I'm not ready anything
important I'm not even in class I know I
got good at turning him on that's that's
all I knew how to do oh my god that when
you needed him you're like [ __ ] can I
bring him back I want to put like an
audio thing just to say what it really
means so hey you look stupid as [ __ ] you
know last story there was this artist
that hid $10,000 in a painting and his
painting was bought for only $88 perfect
wait he did on purpose like as a charity
thing yeah not not a charity thing we
did it I was like a cool surprise
because it's art how did he hide ten
thousand like behind the canvas
he was laundering it sounds like money
laundering I was thinking that so this
was a painting on the canvas yeah so
apparently this there's this vice a
journalist that went to visit this art
gallery here in LA he's like I'm gonna
put it in the ugliest painting whoever
buys this is gonna you just be lucky
know for sure because all the other
paintings in that gallery they were like
really expensive this is the only
affordable one that was there and so
this journalist who said that he bought
this painting was because he had
recognized the artist named Ruby hearts
they thought that he only did
photography so then they found it
interesting that they actually did a
painting that this artist did a painting
so they bought the painting and then
during the art gallery he bumped into
the artist and said hey I'm the one I
bought that that painting and he was
like oh did you notice what the
materials are under and so it says that
it Ruby hearts in the name of the piece
is called artists hearts and then it the
materials are gemstones
tarah tight quartz cash out we would et
cetera so you ash are like wait what
this isn't no one
that he didn't even noticed that so and
he was like patiently waiting for the
the show to finish so you could finally
take that piece home just rip it apart
exactly he doesn't give a [ __ ] about art
I love it yesterday if you can see and
know we had you only bought it because
you recognize the name exactly not
because he liked the [ __ ] joke I
swear to God it is a joke
so then you can see the screws here
although they just took it apart so then
he finally he unscrewed it in the
gallery didn't couldn't wait yeah anyway
he found out this wad of cash and then
all this gold glitter everywhere and
then apparently the artists also put in
some precious stones that he had
collected over the years of visiting
mines and like his grandpa's finger is
all my treasures here you go cuz he was
saying that he wanted he didn't want to
just put money in there just for the
money sake like he actually wanted it to
be meaningful as well using that money
maybe so if grandpa's what he had a ring
his grandpa had a ring and so he put
like stones from that ring in this yeah
pretty much because he said he wanted to
put is this guy dying oh yeah he's
suicidal let's see those rocks oh I
don't have the photos cuz he didn't
really dig through everything so he was
the vice journalist who bought this he
immediately wanted to like cut into the
cash and like you know take it like a
greedy bastard but then people in the
gallery were like wait are you sure you
want to do that it might be worth more
if you just don't touch it like someone
will buy it for more than the cash value
yeah so then he just left it as it
what nah no he didn't he opened it up
give me a break
I would have cut that up he open it up
with any read bag didn't he put it back
in me it's art yeah exactly
you don't do that to art yeah I know yo
[ __ ] I would open that [ __ ] up and I buy
a Honda Element okay oh god you're ready
problems with you the bonding element no
it's just like you know what it is he's
been talking about it for like the last
two years
I just been wanting one for it's just
like the dumbest car it's a square car
right it's a square car but it had like
so much utility it was like literally
made for you not to look cool yeah but
it was made for it to be as useful as
possible and people hated that [ __ ]
car but I loved it and then there was a
reason why it was so hard my cousin has
it yeah like people who like it they
really like it but it was hard to find a
good one because people use it for
utility right so it was all torn up but
I finally find a good one I would buy
another one is that the one that has
like a nozzle in the bottom of the thing
because you can wash it with a [ __ ]
home yeah you can watch the whole inside
with the hose that's crazy I heard about
that actually that's pretty nice like if
you if you actually got this you will
see what happen what would happen is
that before they even say hey maybe you
should I would already cut it open grow
your money just like a Honda Element
immediately you know it appreciates in
my heart I hear you how much do you guys
think it is how much is it you think oh
well the artist said it was $10,000 in
cash
what is it valued yeah what does the
valued know that is a smarter move
though you just kind of sit there and
then someone who's like a millionaire
who doesn't really care about 10 grand
would buy it for me or something
especially if the artist gets really big
and huge and then dies yeah yes some
rich guy just has so much money that he
has no feelings
see that's what I would do if I was an
art collector well I would buy art and
I'd kill the artist yup because Art's
worth more when the artist dies I thank
you
get your AI to kill the artist that way
it's not murder
exactly
did it no other men did not sell our to
me now I mentioned that it was a vice
journalist who bought this painting so
that he actually interviewed the artist
and so one of the questions was what do
you have to say now that you've gotten
our attention with this piece and he was
just saying like you know pay attention
to me while I'm alive because a lot of
artists get famous after the die and he
was like especially in LA it's so rich
in art culture he's just sick of seeing
all his friends and people around him
that are so creative but they can't they
don't have opportunities because they're
still alive and people don't really pay
attention to kill yourself mom - it's
not because they're dead is because most
artists can't organize their [ __ ] that's
true I saw a video that it was on
YouTube like that guy someone so ruins
everything Adam ruins everything you
said the whole art thing is just it's
like a scheme for rich people it's like
if you're a real artist you're probably
not going to be able to get into that
culture because it's not for you it's
not for real artists it's for people to
like push money around and stuff like
it's laundry it's no different than
YouTube [ __ ]
it's like how well can you promote your
[ __ ] like that's really all of this have
you seen that documentary my kid could
paint that oh it's quite oh you have - I
won't watch that because I was so good I
went into the [ __ ] brode museum and
there was a art [ __ ] where a guy just
took a charcoal thing and just drew like
four dicks and I did that in high school
and my [ __ ] was not worth 10 million
dollars you know when he won't even put
it on the wall in the gym thank you or
was that was it maybe you just had to
believe in yourself a little bit
there was another huge ass painting
where it was just like scribbles like
[ __ ] that you like scratched in with a
knife into your dad you think mom's
growing up like just blew their ego up
too much like that's so good that's
amazing
you could sell that in a museum you
should be just like dick I could see it
they invest with like like a [ __ ]
painting on it and you're like this this
is a David stuff this is a self yes and
it's called big fat [ __ ] yeah no I
don't even like you dude you have the
name we should do it
hold art exhibit hell yeah dude doesn't
dorayaki fall ready paint like I do
[ __ ] she paste flowers but sometimes
she bakes [ __ ] as I just look a little
bit like flowers of canvas with just a
single dot in the center yeah in the
museum I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
and I also saw a mirror all I had was
just the frame and it was a [ __ ]
mirror so it's truly and that's the part
that I love about art is there's this
guy named I think it's Duchamp or
something I'm sure some people crack my
ass but he just he back like during the
art scene like I think like a hundred
years ago or less he just [ __ ] took a
toilet and was like this is called
toilet yeah but it's like total [ __ ]
he's making fun of how you can just put
something in the museum call it a name
and then it's like a piece of art there
was like that exhibit on yeah it was
like a party game on that one oh that
was like he or she recreated a party
scene like in the corner to the chatter
just cleaned it up it was like this high
school student that plates something on
the floor I forgot what it was but they
just put something on the floor and I'm
using and then people started crowding
around it dude that's like this [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's my [ __ ] art dude
it's seriously no more complicated than
that drives me crazy I don't understand
contemporary art I think it's garbage
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's up you sexy [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want to
follow us you could check out all our
[ __ ] links in the description box
below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]